ah thanks for coming so early in the
morning thanks to the organizers for
inviting me I realized a few days ago
that I spent exactly half of my life at
this point working on random chaser
which is a really odd observation and
today I think I'll be sitting in front
of certain physicist colleagues and
saying non rigorous things so that would
also be a hopefully at first anyhow
that's what i'll talk about its joint
work with my student k'jon and the
setting is a very familiar one we have
some large domain which we can think of
as just being the cartesian product of
variables with discrete domain and we
have some non negative function that we
would like to sum over the domain so we
just want to compute the so-called
partition function although I won't
necessarily have some statistical
physics or other model in place it's
just a generic function f the only thing
about it that's going to be important
for us is that it's non-negative so when
you take this sum over the entire domain
there are no cancellations that's the
important part and there are several
reasons for which one may want to
compute the partition function here are
some of the standard ones and you can
perhaps think of the stock has proposing
actually although the proposal is not
quite mine but think of it as a generic
alternative to mcmc whereby you try to
compute this sum by optimization meaning
you try to leverage other people's work
on optimization to make the computation
of this of the some efficient and when I
say efficient I mean efficient in
practice so we in terms of the quality
guarantee the idea is we will give an
estimate of the partition function which
is within a multiplicative factor and we
can make the multiplicative factor as
small as we want and we can make it be
true with probability which is
exponential it big in the in the amount
of work that we do so e for the rest of
the top load to simplify things I will
just assume that the domain is the
binary cube and I'm just going to talk
about a 32 approximation of the
partition
function in all the cases that are going
to be of interest the partition function
is exponentially larger than so a 32
approximation is like in a log and
additive approximation you just add a
few bits so just keep that in mind for
the rest of the talk and here is the the
general idea the general idea is not
mine so we're going to assume in a
certain sense that P equals NP and we
will use that to try to do to try to do
the counting by which I mean we have
some piece of software which when the
domain of interest can actually
determine an np-complete problem whether
you solvable or not as is the case for
example for practical satisfiability
instances by which i mean there's lots
of practical satisfiability instances
which have tens or even hundreds
thousand variables that people can solve
in minutes and they actually care about
them and for some of these instances
they also would like to count the number
of satisfying assignments so now the
question is can you leverage all the
effort that they have built in there put
in building the satisfiability solver to
do the counting so the idea is we're
going to repeat a bunch of times where
the number of times just have to do with
the accuracy that we want we're going to
take a random subset of the cube the
size of which is going to be
approximately two to the N minus I and
then we are going to determine the
maximum of our function within this
subset so this is the part that acts
like a black box so again there is the
entire domain there's our function
living on e on the domain that we're
going to take a random subset which I
haven't said how we will specify it yet
and then we will ask hours over to find
the maximum of the function over the
domain the over the sorry over the
random subset and if we get a bunch of
such estimates one for every I from 0 to
n then it's fairly straightforward to
combine them and get an estimate of the
partition function and all this is known
and its prior work and the only
contribution of what I will talk about
is the idea of creating this random
subset as the elements of an
error-correcting code
so let me first walk you through about
the general idea so we'll start with a
thought experiment and we will assume
that somehow we could sort the domain in
terms of F value so Sigma 1 is the
maximum value of sorry F of Sigma 1 is
the maximum value of F F of Sigma 2 is
the second largest one and so forth and
imagine that by some kind of miracle we
could get our hands on the n plus 1
numbers corresponding to F evaluated
that Sigma 2 to the eye so these things
are increasing geometrically so what we
want is b0 b1 b2 b3 and so forth when n
is 6 it's not hard to see that if we
could get our hands on those numbers
then we could get a two approximation to
the partition function and you could
replace two with 1 plus epsilon if the
spacing became 1 plus epsilon instead of
two so in particular it's easy to get
these two expressions and as you can see
they only involve these numbers B sub I
and one is an upper bound and the
partition function in one is a lower
bound and they differ just by a shift of
the index of summation so it's just a
factor of two so this gives it two
approximation p and the proof is sort of
similar to lebesgue integration rather
than trying to integrate vertically we
integrate horizontally and the factor of
two observation is that the green line
gives an upper bound on the integral the
red line is a lower bound in the
integral and if you look at any
horizontal slice the ratio of what's
under the red to what other the green is
at most a fat forever half okay that's
the proof so we want to get our hands on
those numbers and P it's easy to see
that this is also relatively robust by
which I mean that if you don't get those
numbers exactly but you get an estimate
for the I such number which is between B
of I plus C and I minus C then you get a
2 to the 2 c plus 1 approximation
this is straightforward you do this and
by the way all this line of work I
forgot to mention has the sequence of
papers by airman Gomes supper violence
Alvin over the last five years so for
example if we Stan she ate to see to be
too in order to get a 32 approximation
of the partition function it suffices to
find for each I between 0 and n an
estimate of B sub I which is between B
sub x + 2 + bi minus 2 so for example
for be three we just need to find if we
can report any number in this interval
we're good are there any questions at
this point so P in order to come up with
such an estimation we're going to just
use concentration of measure so the
entire point of the top will be to
construct some random variable X such
that it is a reasonable estimator with
Rob ability at least they have so
generically X is any random variable
such that it is with probability at
least one half plus delta less than an
upper bound and probability at least one
half placenta more than a lower bound
and we take several independent samples
of it and we return the median of those
samples then the medium is going to be
between the glow over the upper bound
with exponentially high probability so
that's our plan so we're going to come
up with an estimator for each one of
those vis then repeat a few times and
then just repeat the and then just
report the median of those
so our estimator for now again I'm not
yet telling you how we're going to take
those random sets but when we want to
estimate B sub I we're going to consider
a random set which will have the
property that it is uniform over the
cube and the probability that any
particular element belongs in the random
set is 2 to the minus side so the size
of our set is going to be 2 to the N
minus I in expectation and then our
estimator for the function is going to
be sorry for visa by is going to be the
maximum of our function over the random
set so for example if you think of f as
being merely a 0 1 function so that what
you're really asking is when i take this
random subset I are there still any
solutions left are there still any
places where F evaluates to 1 so it's a
thinning of the original domain that
we're going to do in a random manner and
we're going to thin down to the point
where we expect that the number of
solutions remaining is about one at
least in expectation so for example if
we're aiming for visa by then this is
what the the picture the picture looked
like what we're hoping is that we will
return something which is between B sub
I minus 2 and B sub I plus 2 okay and in
order for that to happen we need that
nothing about here survives the thinning
and that at least something above here
survives and we have you know several
you have an exponential number of
candidates for this to happen
so okay One Direction is super easy and
that's the probability that our
estimated ends up being too big and this
is merely the probability that something
that is too big survived that's in other
words the probability that our random
check includes one of the top 2-2 2-2
the I minus two biggest elements of the
set so just by taking the Union bound
each of this is going to be in the
random set of ability to to the minus I
there is due to the I minus two of them
and now we have from ability a quarter
of overestimating so remember will just
be probability that things don't go
poorly with probability just slightly
bigger than one-half that's AZ that's
the easy direction the the real problem
is avoiding underestimation meaning that
when we specify a random set although in
expectation it's size is right our
random set this kind of clumpy and by
virtual being of kind of clumpy it kind
of hits the set of interests all at once
and it wipes it out another way of
saying it is we don't want it to be the
case that the expected size of the
intersection is realized through a
lottery phenomenon we want it to be me
we want to avoid that so more concretely
to avoid underestimation what we need to
be true is that we although we do avoid
all the elements are p 2 to the i minus
2 we do have some elements up to 2 i
plus 2 so in other words if we let X sub
I be the size of the intersection of our
random set with the first the largest to
to the I plus 2 element we would like
the size of this to be positive and
observe that the expectation of this is
just for so we have two exponential side
set at least for a generic I the top two
to the I plus 2 element and then we have
our random set which was going to have
size about 2 to the N my
sigh we want them to intersect with
probability at least one-half so what
intersection to happen often while
having expected intersection size for so
sometimes it doesn't look like a very
promising situation okay so generically
you have the cube inside the cube there
is some set of size 2 to the alpha N for
some alpha that you don't know it's an
exponentially large set you're going to
take another exponentially large set
your random set the size of your random
set is has at the expected size of the
intersection of the two sets is for
literally four elements and you want
them to intersect with or will it be
more than one-half yet at the same time
you don't want the variance to be very
big so i think this highlights the idea
that we would like the random set that
we have to not be clumpy inside the cube
but instead look like some kind of a
random missed that somehow Pierce is the
cube uniformly everywhere and at the
same time well before I get to this
limit just let me just sort of recap
listen in math so we want to design a
random set such that for uniformly every
element of the cube the probability that
belongs in the set is 2 to the minus I
this set should have a simple
description remember that ultimately
we're supposed to optimize over that set
so we should certainly be able to
describe it efficiently and then if you
take any tricks subset of the cube the
variance of the intersection between our
random set and s a set s for which we
know nothing we don't know anything
about the geometry of s we would like
the variance of this to be small so
quickly it turns out that to minimize
the variance it turns out that the
quantity that you need to control is the
sum over all these things elements of
the unknown set s of the conditional
probability that Sigma prime belongs in
our random set given that Sigma belongs
in a random set so there is a set s you
take any specific element in it and then
you say okay now I reveal to you that my
them said selected this what does this
imply from the probability that some
other element of the set Sigma prime has
also been selected and you know given
that we know nothing about the geometry
of the set set a very sensible goal is
to say that well ideally I would like
you to say nothing about it so we would
like to have pairwise independent so
this is in some sense that golden
standard and if we can achieve this
we're super happy now on the other hand
e the idea that we have pairwise
independent is not obviously easily
compatible with the idea that the set r
is easy to describe by which I mean this
is supposed to be a set which is on one
hand easy to describe well the other
have you must have the property that if
i tell you that something is in a random
set then the probability that something
else is in the random set is the same
whether that's something else is coming
distance one or has hamming distance n
over 2 that's what i'm used to have
pairwise independent okay so the
characteristic function of this set must
be really really unwieldy in any case te
as many of you probably already figured
out this is something that we already
know how to do using so-called linear
error correcting codes so the idea that
we're going to take our random set are
to be the set of solutions to a system
of linear equations modulo 2 so it's
going to be the elements of the cube
that's all a times sigma equals B we're
both a and B are uniformly random 01 so
every element of a is 0 or 1 each with
probability one-half and independently
and every element of b is 0 or 1 with
probability one-half independently and
the first thing to observe is that the
probability that any particular sigma
solve the system of linear equations is
indeed what we want it to be even if we
don't impose any constraint on the
matrix a so for any matrix a even if
this is deterministic or the old zeros
matrix the probability that you match be
just depends on the run
nosov be because after you take this
product you have some fixed vector
that's supposed to match this random
vector well the entries of these are 0 1
with probability 1 half so that
probabilities read email about the eye
so we already get the first part that we
want for pairwise independent the proof
is not significantly more complicated
observe that the probability that both
Sigma and Sigma prime are elements of
the solution set is the probability that
basically one of them you can think of
them as Sigma solves the system and then
the product of Sigma Prime with a is the
same as that of Sigma and then you can
postpone in your decision making in your
choice of B you can postpone this and
then you can just focus on whether this
will happen first or not so this shows
that these two events are independent
and now to estimate the probability that
between a of sigma prime minus sigma z
goes to 0 even that Sigma Prime and
Sigma are distinct we can look at the
vector of their difference and you can
fix any particular bit that you like
there is at least one observe that the
only things that matter in a are the
corresponding columns with which you're
going to take the inner product so now
you can determine the randomness in all
of those problems except for one okay
and you will have a vector here the
parity of which whether it's going to be
0 or not will now simply depend on
finally determining each one of those
random variable so you can think of it
as a deferred decisions proof of the
fact very first fix all other relevant
columns hold one out and then observe
that 2 to the minus I will do the trick
so we get what we want so we do have
pairwise independent and in a certain
sense we're done okay so we can say
define the random set sub I in other
words when you want a subset of size 2
to the N minus I of the cube that is
really like a super fine mist inside the
cube just take a random political
straight
so form this this matrix where each
equation in the matrix has about n over
two variables because you are flipping a
coin that is 50-50 for each entry of the
matrix and then in order to estimate
bisa by simply maximize F subject to
these constraints so that is the that is
the original proposal prior to this work
is it clear perhaps okay so the math
works out but reality doesn't so if you
try to do this the results are not good
unless you you go to anything that is
above a toy problem so here's an example
where you take ten by ten ferromagnetic
as in grid and we set the coupling
strength of the external field so that
it is near criticality by which I mean
that you have a roughly equal
contribution from all states at
different energy levels and what this
plot shows is the following the vertical
axis is the value of the maximum a
logarithmic scale and the horizontal
axis is the number of constraints that
we have added and what happens is except
for a moment by fear that green is
pretty much the correct answer and
moreover observe that what I mentioned
earlier about criticality corresponds to
the fact that there is contribution from
pretty much every distance scale so this
is just an arbitrary line to guide your
eye at 100 minus I so if we had a few
practical strains then we are tracking
the partition function very well but
after you add something like 15 parity
constraints then your soldier dies and
the best solution that you can find is
far far worse than reality and then it
keeps track a little bit again if you
near the very very end dance party is
what I have been saying so far so this
is the dense parity equations are the
equations
which we flip a fair coin for for every
entry of the matrix or a typical
equation has n over 2 but it turns out
that if you naively attempt to specify
this matrix by saying set every entry to
one with our ability p where p some
number less than one-half you also don't
get good results so partner what was the
soldier here we tried cplex but we've
also tried different satisfiability
solvers we've tried local search pretty
much nothing works and the reason that
nothing works in some sense makes a lot
of sense okay you have your constraint
satisfaction problem or your easing
order meaning that each of the factors
is hiring local it entails a very small
number of variables that's good and then
what do you do you throw in constraints
that have n over two variables each okay
where you won't end to be something
non-trivial so it would be nice event
for example was at least a thousand and
each of these constraints is a parity
constraint which means if it's not happy
you have 500 choices of which variable
to flip to make it happy right by virtue
of being a parity constraint any change
of any variable will actually satisfy
this so from the point of view of the
solver there is absolutely no guidance
on how to proceed inter search the
branching factor is immense so it has
long been understood that it would be
nice to achieve pretty much the same
effect by using short particles rates
except like I said if you do it naively
by simply specifying the matrix a it
doesn't work you get very very bad
results so the the contribution that we
made was they realize that well we'll
make two I guess let me first talk about
about this one the first one is we're
going to exploit the fact that these are
random linear codes as opposed to just
good codes which means that we can
alternatively express this random set
the subset of the cube that forms the
code words simply a sort of the up
projection of a lower dimensional set
into the cube
an explicit matrix G so now I'm saying
okay I have a sub tube it's dimension is
going to be n to the minus I so the code
words are just taking the entire sub
cube and filter it through this matrix
and you get your code words the result
of which is that instead of solving the
constrained optimization problem
maximize F over the entire original cube
subject to solving the CSP by the
linearity of the constraints we can
rewrite it as maximize an unconstrained
optimization problem over a lower
dimensional cube where now what you
maximize is f of X passed through the
generator matrix so one part of this
story is positive meaning that for the
interesting values of I the size of the
domain has shrunk by an exponential
amount the downside is that now your
function f has become a black box so it
used to be that in most cases you have a
syntactic representation of F like f in
satisfiability formula or it's an easy
model now you basically say okay here's
my ex what code word that this
corresponds to please tell me what's the
value of F there so you are directly
accessing far away points in the in the
higher space so you can say that perhaps
any sort of nice continuity properties
that you might have have for F in the
original domain are kind of gone
nevertheless for problems for which you
did not exploit the syntactic
representation of X of F which is pretty
much whenever you use any kind of
randomized local search this is
irrelevant so if you were using learn
amides local search in the first place
you were already using a black box so it
doesn't really matter and it works
remarkably well so in fact this is how
we actually got the answer for this
particular for this particular model so
the first claim is me if you are
basically doing maximum likelihood
estimation by solving some kind of
optimization problem through a
stochastic random walk you can pretty
much use that code as is and with a
little bit of overhead be able to
computer partition function so GU too
thick ie yes that's right that's right
that's right g is the yes that's right
so this is a case in which we don't say
anything about Park City so we'll just
use the knife sophistical properties of
the original final ensemble and that the
the downside is like I said that now f
becomes a black box so that was the
first contribution and it works well for
problems in which you proceed by
randomized local search in the in the
second contribution we realize that well
for certain problems for example for
satisfiability the reason that people
are able to get to the point where they
can solve problems with a hundred
thousand variables is because they put a
tremendous amount of effort into
engineering that exploits the syntactic
representation of your formula so for
example they will try to find a good
embedding of the formula all sorts of
tricks and if you if you go with the the
route i presented earlier all this is is
gone so you would like to maintain the
syntactic representation and then the
idea is to use low-density parity-check
codes and for the probably very few of
you who have never seen those before let
me just explain what the what the main
idea is in using these codes so this is
my matrix a i have n columns and I Rose
exactly like before and I want most of
them to be zeros so that the oddity of
my constraint so that each of the
equations has few variables so that when
the equation is unhappy in order to fix
it the branching factor in the search is
small so in the original ensemble
everything was blue with probability
one-half I could have made everything
blue with probability P and like I told
you that doesn't work so I'm going to do
now something which is only slightly
more intelligent than this I will
maintain the sparsity but I will
additionally require a lower bound on
the number of blues in each column so
specifically I will require that every
column hazard at least three blues
and here's what happened imagine for
example that I have some some solution
out here and then I go when I flip a
single bit so I used to have an era used
to have a code word I flip a single bit
as a result of which now each of the
equations in which this big participates
is violated it's a palette equation as
soon as you change a single bit it has
to be validated so now if I want to fix
this without simply just going back to
where i was i can try to change a
different bit and let's say if i change
this bit i now have the fact that this
equation is fixed because there are two
things that have been changed and this
equation also got fixed this one didn't
get fixed but moreover i also introduced
a new mistake there's another violated
equation and then i can do it again and
because this is a talk it works out
beautifully and that cycle of length 3
everything gets fixed right so this is
the code word I just dance 3 from my
original code word ok the point is
though that if I insist that every
column of the matrix has at least three
blues there are not going to be any such
such cycles the idea is e as soon as you
change a variable that variable
participates by virtue of having degree
3 in three constraints in each of these
constraints you have to now change
something and now that you've changed it
you still have two new constraints that
just got violated so basically you get
an explosive branching process of
equations as soon as you change a single
bit and this is what makes it a good
error correcting code so you change a
single bit and then the next closest
code what is very far away at least
typically I mean there could be
exceptions but by and large you get an
explosive branching process for a long
time before the cycles begin to close
and we start getting phenomena like this
so just by changing the theme just by
changing the
but you can think of this in the
original in the original formulation we
had the balls and bins experiment this
is again a Boston beans experiment the
only requirement is that every bit gets
at least three balls it's exactly the
same nothing else changed so so by doing
this it turns out that things get get
dramatically better and solver is happy
because the typical constraint now has
maybe four or five six seven variables
something that can deal with them in
closets for example too often have that
length yet at the same time we have by
virtue of having an error correcting
code we have a set that still has this
mistiness property that I talked about
earlier that manages to keep the
variance of the intersection small so
concretely this is a little bit of a
cartoon but not entirely so what this
plot shows is the conditional
probability that Sigma prime is a code
word given that Sigma is a code word
that's the vertical axis and the
horizontal axis is the distance of Sigma
Prime from Sigma normalized x divided by
n so in the ideal ensemble the one that
has pairwise independence corresponds to
this horizontal red line where that
probability is completely independent of
the distance between Sigma and Sigma
Prime so this is what we're aiming for
if on the other hand you take the
original dance ensemble and you merely
try to specify it you get this really
nasty tail back here this is a huge bump
and this speaks precisely to the fact
that you don't have an error correcting
code so you're going to have pairs of
elements that are very close to each
other you're going to have clumps in
contrast by I mean we use a specific
LDPC construction but it doesn't really
matter by using a low-density
parity-check code as I described you get
something which is like this you get the
green line and the green line you know
it has a few operations and dealing with
those is sort of non-trivial but for the
most part it tracks the red line
exceptionally well and in fact the
[ __ ] it boils down to zero here and
here is a good thing is not
take it even further suppresses the 11
further suppresses the varia there are
sorry the variance of the off of other
random variable and this is a picture
which is actually by explicit
enumeration of counting all the code
words in reporting them for relatively
small and I think maybe n is either 32
or 40 for this example and you see that
you already get fairly close to the
limiting behavior and i forgot to say
that the the vertical axis is is
logarithmic so that's why they work
because you managed to track the
conditional probability that you get
from long equations almost perfectly by
using equations that are far shorter by
being clever about how you construct the
equations and i'll just talk a little
bit about me about the computational
complexity aspect so if you think of
your original solver your original
server is forgetting the forgetting the
additional constraints that we put in is
moving around in some kind of energy
landscape and its trying to find let's
say a minimum of your function listing
that sort of max it's a minute just flip
it around so ok it's doing this thing
and remember that our assumption is that
that's something that your server can
already do reasonably well for the
domain of interest because if you can't
even maximize the function then hoping
to estimate the partition function is
completely hopeless so this is what your
original folder is doing and now what
we're going to do is we're going to
superimpose on this the Hamiltonian that
corresponds to our system of linear
equations so what this picture is
supposed to represent is you think of
the two dimensions as the binary cube
the third dimension is the value of the
function you're looking for a minimum so
now we'll take this picture and I'm
going to add to it at least in the
logarithmic domain the function which
has the same domain and simply count the
number of violated equations in my
system and then what I'm asking for is
to find let's say an area where this
function is zero and then we can also
always scale this so that we're looking
for a zero so we're looking for a joint
zero of the new energy landscape so what
we would like to achieve
Eve is that the energy landscape that
results after we move this one is not
much harder for the solver if we were
using the dance ensemble the one that I
talked about originally well that's
terrible because it's incredibly spiky
on another hand the whole point one
could say almost of modern coding theory
is to try to create energy functions
energy landscapes for error correcting
codes which have the property that they
kind of look like this so i would like
to argue that this looks very much like
a modern error correcting code in the
following sense so again two dimensions
correspond to the binary cube third
dimension corresponds to the number of
violated equations and the bottom of
each one of those regions corresponds
the code word so when you want to
transmit information you select the code
word that you want to send you can think
of it as a little ball you place it at
the bottom of this basin that's the
perfect code word then you ship it
through the channel the channel perturbs
it but hopefully by not too much so the
channel perturbs it so that we don't
land out here you still learn
sufficiently close to the original that
can naive algorithm something like
gradient descent which is mostly what BP
decoding does will bring you back down
that make sense so the idea is that
superimposing is that superimposing such
a such a hamiltonian to the hamiltonian
of the original problem doesn't make the
life of the solver significantly harder
because practically what happens is most
of the time the linear equations to be
solving to say this is a cartoon in the
sense that actually these areas are far
larger not what is depicted here but
most of the time they have nothing to
say and at some point they just kick in
and say okay you know what forget it if
we're here then the only reasonable
place to go is to go down and then it
takes over so your original solver
either solves the original problem at
any given moment or is doing airport
decoding and in some sense both of these
problems are supposed to be easy the
original problem is supposed to be easy
by assumption the second problem is easy
because the coding is easy because we've
decided the codes to be like this and so
the the end result is that when we use
low-density parity-check codes we can
scale to problems with thousands of
variables and in particular the
resulting running time the running time
of maximizing the functions subject to
the additional constraints and finding a
good lower bound for for the maximum is
almost transparent so the running time
for let's say when you want to prove
that a formula is satisfiable
satisfiable subject to additional parity
constraint is comparable to the running
time of finding a satisfying assignment
without any such additional constraints
now the answer to scalability side is
much much harder partly because proving
an satisfiability is generically hard
but one thing that we can say is that in
all problems where ground truth is known
we get exactly the same accuracy as by
using long parity constraints and the
method can be quite can be quite a lot
faster I'll just close with giving some
some plots so these are experimental
results and each point that you see
represents one CNF formula this is a
collection of about 200 CNF for colors
that people use to to measure the
performance of satisfiability counting
solvers and they are sorted so this is
this one is easier to explain this is
time and this is the logarithm base 2 of
the number of the amount of time it
takes when we use longer sword vs using
loss as the PC to divide to provide the
same answer and you can see that the
speedup is can be from a factor of 4 or
fat32 256 or even to a thousand and in
some sense our I think this will
actually continue going for a long time
the only problem is that we don't have
solver formulas for which we know the
ground truth that are big enough
so we do get meaningful results for
formulas that are better you know
practically interesting this plot is I
have to spend a little bit more time to
explain like I said we can get lower
bounds on the partition function so this
is what this little hat is and this is
the ratio between the lower bound that
we get versus the lower hound that a
soldier can deliver when it is fed with
longer source so we would like this
quantity to be big we want our lower
bound to be significant so then you
first take one logarithm so this you can
interpret the inner logarithm of telling
you how many more parity constraints you
cannot how many powers of two our lower
bound is than the one by X or and then
the second logarithm is so that it fits
in the plot so the number of additional
constraints that we can add can be as
high as 22 the 10 so this is like a
factor of 2 to the thousand 24 times
better lower bound and so
so I the lower bound is given whenever
you find a satisfying assignment in
other words if you give me a formula and
I can add a bunch of constraint I
constraint each of which kills half
satisfying assignment and in spite of
adding I constraints I can still find a
satisfying assignment this proves that
the form proves in the probabilistic
sense that the formula has at least 2 to
the I assignments right so the point is
by adding short constraints we can allow
the solver to find solutions and
survived far far far deeper than by
adding long concert if you have long
constraints after 10 or 15 constraint
the solver just gives us so and that's
it thank you
all right questions yes about the forum
of generating the benchmarks well you
all know there's a number of solutions I
was wondering if one could take a
simpler problem like thousands of said
well you know the wrong and convert it
to a CNN it or even nae for example for
which we have very nice bounce for not
only quad or which is even closer in
some sense to what people care about the
only problem with this benchmarks right
is the fact that they all say it's a
mean-field model so so there is no
geometry and the practitioners don't
care as much about it in the encoding
you might wake praise on gadget on some
structure but why would I need to do
that I can take a random energy formula
yes and use that so our main problem was
to see if we can scale with formulas
that people actually care about like ten
twenty thousand variables from some kind
of a VLSI circuit and see when you add
those additional constraint how much
pain do you induce on the solver but
that was a main thing and by the way
these results are by clicking this over
as a black box so although I showed it
in the slides currently the code that we
have doesn't exploit the fact that you
know what the energy landscape looks
like for an error correcting code so
what we're working on now is also
additionally exploiting this explicitly
in the design of the earth optimization
we had a talk clear in a workshop I'm
not sure that was yet describing some
kind of similar ideas it's very similar
so how did you were compared with so you
saw this compass comparison where it was
log log so that was their lower bound so
they use still long x horse so um no
comment okay well okay let me let me
just make one comment in many of those
practical problems that exists a very
small set of variables that actually
determine what's going on so if you can
identify those which is a completely
orthogonal problem then you have a much
much problem too easy a problem to deal
with and to that problem you can apply
longer sort the problem is that
identifying those those variables that
literally lock what is going on can be
quite tricky so when they say that it
works on problems that are very very big
what they mean to say that they work on
problems are very very big which are
rendered very very small by being able
to identify those variables we're using
our code literally our first experiment
is take their code change nothing other
than the error correcting code that you
use just change the matrix that was the
only thing and then you get a speed-up
of a factor of a thousand unrealistic
for business
other questions go already good we'll
see you in 10